hey everyone
welcome back to another video by simply
learn
in today's video we're going to learn
all about angular dependency injection
now i'm sure you've learned about
angular basics
if you haven't then check out our other
videos on angular
also if you haven't subscribed to our
channel already make sure to hit the
subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update so let's begin
first we'll have a look at what's in
store for us
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern
and finally i'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin what exactly is
dependency injection
so let's consider this i'm sure you're
aware that angular uses the concept of
components
the entire ui of the application is
divided into several components
now what of all of these components
perform similar tasks
be it accessing the database rendering
images
etc now instead of writing the same
piece of code for every component
you could write the code once and then
perhaps inject the same code into every
component
now this is supported by dependency
injection
now to give you a better example
consider two classes a and b
now let's assume that a uses the objects
of class b
and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of class
b is created so that a can access its
objects
with using dependency injection we move
the creation and
binding of dependent objects outside of
the class that depend on them
so dependency injection or di keeps the
code more flexible
testable and mutable also classes can
inherit external logic without having to
create on its own and lastly di benefits
directives
pipes and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider class postal details
that is dependent on the number and the
address class
in the postal details class the
constructor
creates copies of the number and address
so when you instantiate a new postal
details class
the constructor instantiates a unique
number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code
let's assume that the number and address
class constructors now accept
parameters when we change the numbers
class
the postal details class gets broken now
to overcome
this what we need to do is we need to
pass parameter
to the number constructor so this
applies to address as well
the first drawback of using this
traditional method
is that the code is not very flexible
anytime the dependencies change
the postal details class needs to be
changed as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address
even if you change the number and
address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this
we make use of dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern
where a class receives its dependencies
from an external source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example
we have moved the definition of
dependencies from
inside the constructor to the
constructor's parameters
so the postal details class doesn't
create the dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create
the dependencies anymore so with that we
overcome the drawbacks of not using di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is
let's look at a simple demonstration to
understand the concept better
now services classes modules
components all of these are benefactors
of dependency injection
so in the demo i'm going to be showing
how dependency injection can be used
with the help of services
and injecting these services into
classes so the main
thought behind this is normally
components are used to
ensure just a good user experience these
components do not
generally execute tasks so to execute
these tasks we make use of
services so a component can delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
any network related issues etc to a
particular service
and these services can be made available
to components
with the same thought what i'm going to
be doing is i'll be creating a service
that performs the task of displaying an
employee list
later we're going to inject this service
into the class using
dependency injection so let's head to
our visual studio code for the
demonstration
all right so as discussed i'll have to
first create
a component that displays a button for
the employee
and then i have to create a service
class and inject it into my component
now this service holds the employee
details such as name
employee id email id etc
so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type nggc
and the name of the component i'm
providing is amp
info getting your learning started is
half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
all right so as you can see here in my
app folder i have the component
with four different files all right so
the next thing we have to do is we have
to create
a service so to create that we make use
of the command
ng g s you can either give s
or service and the service name i'm
providing is records
so let me just say records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a
spec.ts file and the dot ts file
all right so now the service contains
all the employee data that needs to be
displayed
right so let's go ahead and write the
data so first we're going to make use of
three arrays
i'm going to be displaying employee
records for three employees
so i'll have to create three arrays and
provide certain information
so let's go ahead and do that
all right so the array i'm creating is
called info one
for the first employee and i'm going to
be
passing
information like name employee id and
the email id so the arrays of type
string and within which
let me just mention the details i'm
giving random
information i'm just saying adam taylor
and some random employee id
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so i'm going to be creating
three records so i'll just copy the same
thing and paste for the rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
and let me change the name of the idea
as well
all right so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component
we make use of the method for the same
right so this method
returns the employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
i'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot info 1.
all right i'm gonna be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
i'm just gonna return different arrays
here
all right and lastly info 3 all right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component
we need three more arrays right three
more arrays that will receive this data
let's go back to our component dot ts
file here
and then type in the following code
so i've created three arrays again or in
four received one
two and three now what we need to do is
we have to accept the information that
is being sent
from the service correct now as
i mentioned services are implemented
with the help
of dependency injection so what we need
to do is we'll have to first
import the service into the component.ts
file
the key reason behind doing this is that
when angular creates this component
an instance of the service class is also
made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so i'll say import
[Music]
records services
i'm sorry service from
and let's say records dot service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created
in the providers area of the component
all right so
let's just say providers
and then say records service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class
right however to access this instance an
object is also created
so this object will in turn access the
methods and variables of the service
class
so for that we have to create another
object so let's do that here in our
constructor method
let's say constructor
private and the object i'm creating is
called
our service you can give a name of your
choice
and then i'm going to just say records
service
all right now this object will help me
retrieve data from
the service so let's go ahead and use
this
in order to get the employee details all
right
i've created three different methods
here get info from service class two
one and three and these methods will
retrieve the data
and add it to our array here that is
info received all right and lastly
we'll have to create an unordered list
in our html file here we haven't added
anything
so let me get rid of this
so now i have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the ui
right
so as you can see i've created buttons
for three different employees
and then i've made use of a bootstrap
class called
list group info and then i've
interpolated info which displays the
contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot ts
file
we have to bind them with the button so
since it is bound with the click
event every time you click on the button
the
information is displayed so now the last
thing we have to do
is we'll have to create a custom html
tag for the component
and then add it to the main component so
let's just
do that let me copy this here
and then in my appcomponent.html let me
get rid of this
and then let me just create this i've
just created
the custom html tag for my component
and now just to beautify the code i'll
write a heading
and let's say employee
details and then i'll also add
the simply learn logo say
image source
[Music]
i've i've added the image here so let me
just say
logo dot png
i've also added some styling to it all
right
so now let me just save this and have a
look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then
employee details heading and then we
have three different
buttons created that is employee one two
and three and when i click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name
the id and the email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection
and inject a service class into a
component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
so with that we come to the end of this
session i hope you found this tutorial
helpful
i'd also suggest you check out our
previous video on angular services to
get a better understanding of that
concept
so thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here